I think another thing I notice is um you
find just one thing that a character
loves or they hold dear and then you
find the most brutal way to rip it away
from them
like I said before with Michelle like
just the way her family gets
systematically torn away from her or
like Jamie it's just bang your sword
hand is gone now what do you do is that
something that you try to do do you try
to do you try this find really how to
destroy your character's life in an
exceptionally specific way based on what
they hold dear do I do
I don't I now that I've said it are you
questioning whether you're a sadist or
not oh no I think you you know you you
have to take your characters and you
have to put them through crises that's
what that's what fiction and drama is
all about is it's not you know your your
hero has a really good time but things
have to happen that close the characters
to to question who they are and what
their place in the world is and what the
meaning of it all is to go through the
dark nights of the soul and times of
fear and terror and all of this you know
I've always taken as my mantra the
William Faulkner's words in his Nobel
Prize acceptance speech where he said
the human heart in conflict with itself
is the only thing worth writing about I
think that's true of all fiction of
literary fiction such as Faulkner wrote
but also of science fiction and fantasy
and historical novels and nurse novels
and whatever I mean if you have if you
have real characters grappling with real
problems the human heart in conflict
with itself doesn't matter if it's in a
castle or a spaceship or whatever if you
have that then then you have power and
if you don't then you don't and and
Jamie losing a hand losing the very
thing that he defined himself on is is
crucial to I I think where I want to go
with the character and he questions what
do you what do you make of yourself if
you've lost that and of course I have
teary and now going through similar
things I mean he's always focused on the
things that he he did not have like his
father's respect or admiration or you
know perhaps women didn't look on him
the way he would have liked them to look
on him and all that stuff but in the
aftermath of the events of the recent
books he's now realizing the things that
he did have that he's now lost like the
Lannister name and a vast fortune in
gold that could allow him to buy and
sell anyway he's been reduced to the
most primal difficult situation where he
has nothing but the clothes on his back
and even those don't belong to him and
his his wits his tongue
so yeah that's what that's what drama
comes out of I love exploring that stuff
do you ever like do something like cut
Jaime's hand off and then go poker I
wish I could still see him sword fight
why did I do that
there is something you've written and
you've gone why did I do that no no no
I'm pretty happy with most of what I've
done you know there are there are a few
things that that you were not aware of
because as a gardener with the kind of
writing style that I that I use I go
down a lot of dead ends so there are
moments of why the hell did I do that
but they never appear in the books
because hopefully I say that before the
book comes out and then I I rip out that
chapter or I revise that chapter so you
know something something different
happens instead and it feels better it
works better for me so hopefully none of
those things will make it at the print
now though you know you never know I
look back on books I wrote
20 years ago you known before before
Game of Thrones and I did by the way
guys write books and short stories
before Game of Thrones available at your
local library
oh there are a lot of them there but I
look back at some of them and and see
from the benefit of hindsight things I
could have done differently things I
could have done better you hope you're
always improving but still the game of
Thrones is perfect I think so pretty
much yeah I have I am bad with eye color
but that's what Elio and Linda for they
they correct me on my eye color and I
have a horse that changes sex he's not
supposed to change sex or she's not
supposed to change he just seems to do
so he rides these androgynous horse I
think it was brands for section it was I
think it was dance um yeah that changes
from a a mayor to a a gilding or
something in that between books so that
was pointed out to be my fans my fans
are very eagle-eyed they miss they
missed nothing you bloody bastards
[Laughter]